this is the best way of life for me to
live and I'm gonna do it as long as I
can this is my sod house where I keep
meat mostly when I'm trying to keep it
cooler in the spring when it warms up
here sod is just the roots and some of
the soil that's on the top of the ground
this makes really good insulation this
is awesome to use for a lot of things
besides just the sod once it dries out
it's really good for wick I make a lamp
sometimes with it in the winter use it
wipe things up this spill you can use it
for toilet paper
it's supposed to be antibiotic I guess
it's good to put on it
[Music]
tearing off the roots bottom of it
trying to get it as thick piece as
possible just like a raw fiberglass
insulation I'm gonna see if I can carry
this thing
right now
[Music]
looks pretty good I think I'm all done
for now I'm gonna keep one piece of sod
here in case bears come and rip more off
now when I'm down in Fairbanks I do my
laundry at the laundromat and I never
get excited about going to the
laundromat
but I really enjoy doing laundry out
here I've got a great view birds are
singing I can't think of a better way to
spend the afternoon my philosophy is
keep your technology simple things won't
go wrong it's not much they can go wrong
with this washing machine right here
step 2 put it through the old wringer
this wringer here used to be my mom she
bought this 50 years ago
how many washing machines that were
bought today will be running in 50 years
this ringer does have limitations down
around 30 below it starts to freeze 30
blows about the limit for doing laundry
out here okay all those left is to hang
it up
blonde is all done
probably being dried by tonight
if I was in town I'd still be on the
road headed to the laundromat what I
want to do now is get it warmed up in
here because I'd rather not sleep in 13
below this is a system that Arctic
people always used to start fire because
you can actually do it with minutes even
if it's 40 below zero I'll put this
mouthpiece and it's made out of caribou
antler
let's go support it
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
fire